Vladimir Putin has taken more than
Ukrainian sailors captive in the Azov
sea his high stakes military and
political maneuvering has ensured the
group of 20 meeting will be dominated by
two people the kremlin chief and his US
counterpart donald trump just like last
year's g20 when Russian meddling in US
elections overshadowed the agenda the
presidents haven't met one-on-one since
their July summit in Helsinki where
Trump's behavior toward Putin was
bizarrely submissive leaving huge
questions looming over Buenos itis
European leaders and his advisors back
home all wants to show a united front
and that's really our objective it
doesn't really matter so much what
whatever practical steps are as long as
we can show united front because
remember Putin's objective is to sow
discord and disunity in the Western
alliance Europe's geography dooms it to
being caught in the middle of Moscow and
Washington politically when tensions
flare in those capitals Brussels feels
the burn it will be difficult for the
Europeans to see their concerns on
global trade addressed while navigating
other diplomatic danger zones there are
so many things going on there that could
cause cause problems I mean you're a Xi
Jinping will be there so it's possible
that if there is language on trade that
Trump will demand that it says something
very negative about China or that others
will want to say something very negative
about protectionism and Trump will
insist that protectionism is good and
America is first don't forget you also
have the Saudis there as Ian bond points
out even more political drama will be
ensured by the presence of Saudi
Arabia's Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman accused of ordering the murder of
journalist Jamal Khashoggi many European
leaders have expressed outrage and
scaled back ties but Trump hasn't one
thing is certain about this g20 there
are going to be some awfully awkward
photo ops